do you remember the first time that you  realized that not everyone's intentions  are good i grew up very sheltered always  thought the world was a good place  and the first time i realized that it  wasn't was when a coach that i looked up  to like a father like  literally spent so much time with him  thought he was so cool he hit on me the  second i turned 18. tried to get me in  the gym alone tried to seduce me and i  literally did not see it coming he  seemed like such a good husband such a  good father and that  really changed like how i looked at the  world it taught me that the people that  are trying to help you aren't actually  always trying to help you